[Música]
Hola bienvenidos esto es una semana en
el mundo el programa de France 24 en el
que los periodistas son los invitados y
Con quienes conversamos de una manera
más distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos destacados de la semana para
conversar sobre la selección de temas
que tenemos para hoy saludamos a Andrés
pascoe periodista director editorial de
Cuestión puntocom Andrés Bienvenido al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos Y qué
tal termina usted la semana Muchas
gracias por invitarme un placer estar
aquí con todos ustedes y con tu
auditorio pues termina intensa la semana
no ha estado compleja Yo creo que sí hay
bastantes temas que abordar no faltan
los temas complejos a lo largo de las
semanas las noticias no descansan Andrés
de nuevo gracias por estar con nosotros
ahora saludo a Iván aviseman él es
periodista economista politólogo y
fundador y editor de semana en el
mostrador
Iván bienvenido Gracias por acompañarnos
y qué tal termina su semana
como todas las semanas últimamente muy
cansado pero pero bueno cuando uno tiene
el periodismo un poco implantado en el
alma es una adrenalina Pero gracias por
la por la oportunidad gracias por la
invitación Iván Pero le pido que tenga
un poquito de energía para que nos
acompañe aquí con su opinión en el
programa pese al cansancio que tenemos
todos después de esta semana intensa de
trabajo y aquí en el estudio de France
24 está con nosotros stefanopotzone ls
periodista corresponsal internacional
actualmente cubre para CNN los hechos
que ocurren en Colombia y en Venezuela
Stefano Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
el estudio y cómo termina usted la
semana bien en Bogotá por una vez hay
sol y ya esto es razón de felicidad pero
me agrego a los comentarios de los otros
huésped una semana interesante donde
latinoamérica maneja historia importante
para todo el mundo Entonces interesante
analizarlas temas importantes en la
región de América Latina no faltan
tampoco Bueno pero ustedes también nos
pueden acompañar con sus opiniones con
sus comentarios con sus preguntas
ustedes ya lo saben estamos en las redes
sociales arroba franz24- bajo ese arroba
santilogo que es mi cuenta personal y
nuestra etiqueta es numeral una semana
en el mundo f24 importante el f24 para
que dejen allí los comentarios pues
vamos a entrar en materia comenzamos
este recorrido por esas filtraciones a
través de las redes sociales de
documentos clasificados de la
inteligencia militar de Estados Unidos
entre otros temas daban detalles de la
estrategia y también del plan de ayuda
de Estados Unidos la otan y la Unión
Europea a Ucrania deja en evidencia
también hechos de espionaje a países
aliados de Estados Unidos como Corea
como Israel y todavía está por verse si
esta información ha sido manipulada o no
y también pues el desarrollo de esta
investigación dirá Cuál era el fin que
tendría la filtración de estos
documentos que dan muchas dudas y el
impacto que pueda tener esto sobre la
guerra en Ucrania es tal vez el foco
principal de este tema también deja
en entredicho esa relación que tiene la
casa blanca con algunos países aliados y
con otros países no tan cercanos como
Rusia y China comienzo entonces dándole
la palabra a Andrés impresiona Es sobre
este estas filtraciones Estados Unidos
no es nuevo que esté haciendo espionaje
a sus países más cercanos a sus países
aliados pero pero vuelve a quedar mal
parado a nivel diplomático en la escena
internacional
bueno en efecto no es nuevo cada vez que
hay una una fuga de información de este
tipo lo primero que sabemos es que
espían a los británicos y que expidan a
los franceses y que espiana los
israelíes pero a mí sí me llama la
atención la reacción internacional ha
sido mucho menos enérgica en esta
ocasión yo creo que ya todos están
acostumbrados a que los espían y lo
asumen como pues que así es esto no
estoy seguro que muchos de ellos
probablemente también espían a Estados
Unidos lo que es interesante mencionar
ahorita es que acaban de arrestar a un
presunto sospechoso bueno sospechoso de
haber sido quien hizo las filtraciones
el Jack Zaira que estaba en un grupo de
de en un chat de amigos
Gamers y como al parecer amantes de las
armas y medio racistas y a través de ahí
se fue entonces lo que lo que hace esta
historia más o menos entretenida es en
primer lugar
lograron filtrar
lograron infiltrar si lograron sacar
documentos Pero no lograron esconderse
los agarraron muy fácilmente Y entonces
Eso habla Pues que tenían sus áreas de
oportunidad en en hacer este tipo de
cosas por otro lado lo que están
diciendo es que la información no es
especialmente grave y como bien dices tú
pues no está tampoco precisamente
confirmada lo que a mí más me ha llamado
la atención del asunto es
si de ser cierta la información filtrada
hay mucha más angustia respecto a
Ucrania de lo que se nos hace ver y
saber no los estadounidenses sí parecen
estar bastante preocupados de cómo se
está desarrollando la guerra y cómo
puede concluir y la respuesta de Ucrania
también No ha sido muy enérgica en torno
a esta filtración supuestamente fueron
dados a conocer algunos datos de
posiciones a nivel militar algo de la
estrategia pero Ucrania tampoco ha dado
mayor relevancia a estas filtraciones
Iván desde su perspectiva cómo queda
Estados Unidos a nivel diplomático y se
une usted a lo que ha dicho Andrés que
tal vez ha habido menos revuelo
internacional si lo comparamos con
momentos anteriores donde también hubo
filtraciones
Mira yo creo que a ver uno a lo mejor se
pone un poco cínico en esta profesión
uno Trata de no ser escéptico pero no
cínico pero a mí me parece que estamos
viviendo
la transparencia es un valor de época y
la verdad que tratar de mantener
secretos es cada vez más difícil lo que
dijo mi colega acercase a ver si es
cierto lo también lo que sabemos es que
si es verosímil es cierto como dicen
entonces Más allá de Qué porcentaje lo
que se filtró es verdad y no es verdad
Creo que una vez más confirma que es muy
difícil yo lo veo como algo bueno
viviendo El periodismo mantener secretos
segundo creo que si uno Sigue los temas
de cerca no hay nada mucho choqueante no
hay nada que que uno diga Guau no Que
impresionante es impresionante lo fácil
que se filtró si es la versión que que
en las últimas 24 horas se ha dado que
fueron estos Gamers que uno de estos
Gamers lo habían desafiado acerca de
verdad
que él decía tener y que empezó a
filtrarles como para probarle a este
grupo con los que jugaba que
efectivamente esto era cierto y después
más del punto de vista político a ver
hace meses que que que que que que que
que información tanto de occidente como
de de Europa del este o más cercana a la
visión de Chile de Unión soviética o
perdón de Rusia era que que nadie iba a
ganar y lo que dice esto es que Estados
Unidos más o menos piensa lo mismo
no va a cambiar el balance y yo espero
eventualmente más tarde que sea más
temprano que tarde que que que que se
logre una paz que está realmente
desestabilizando Europa y aquí en el
estudio France veinticuatro Stefano sus
impresiones pues muy poco que han
agregar obviamente los colegas ya han
analizado el tema y no es un tema que yo
personalmente he cubierto desde cerca
claramente Sí cada vez que hay una
de este de este tipo la análisis que se
hace siempre es que no es sorprendente
que que un superpoder como Estados
Unidos opera de esta manera pero
obviamente nadie quiere hacerse ver con
las manos en la jarra de la mermelada
Entonces esta vez fueron
les salió de las manos y obviamente no
es una una victoria a nivel diplomático
pero probablemente la próxima semana
estaremos hablando de otra cosa me
imagino usted le queda también la
sensación que lo que sorprende aquí de
todo este caso es que la filtración fue
por parte de los mismos estadounidenses
no ha sido como en otros casos Donde
había factores externos que filtraban
estaba en su momento Wikileaks que era
aparte de Estados Unidos en este caso es
alguien al interior de Estados Unidos
que ha dejado filtrar esto esto también
dice mucho y también aquí haciendo un
poco de especulación y montándonos un
poco en una en un guión de película de
Hollywood un poco de Conspiración no
interna dentro de los partidos o de lo
que puede haber ahí claro de ser la
noticia del día de en que estamos
grabando en este momento Es que la
fuerza de seguridad estadounidense
acaban de detener una presunto
responsable por esta por esta filtración
hay que ver lo que lo que las imágenes
llevarán a cabo y como y sabe también
entender lo que vamos a saber de estas
imágenes porque estamos hablando de
temas sensibles obviamente
la inversa le pregunto por Rusia que es
un país que se menciona mucho en estas
filtraciones y muchos decían que el
kremlin estaba mejor dicho
lambiéndose Los Bigotes Como dice el
dicho común por la información que había
llegado la respuesta del kremlin fue la
información no es para nada despreciable
es bastante jugosa y e importante y la
vamos a ver con pinzas Rusia aquí en
toda esta ecuación usted que qué
posición cree que puede adoptar
yo no creo que cambie mucho lo que tenía
planeado con la guerra antes o después O
sea el tema que por ejemplo por lo que
uno se entera por la prensa que lo más
sensible de la guerra era que revelaba
las posiciones donde Ucrania tenía sus
defensas antiaéreas Y que ahora Rusia
Podría tener al tener esa información
desviar sus aviones y sus drones Bueno
lo mismo puede hacer Ucrania al saber yo
como no soy experto en temas de defensa
lo quiero aclarar es una opinión
informada que estoy dando pero a mí la
verdad que no no no creo que cambie
dramáticamente esto más como para para
lo que yo llamo el círculo rojo de la
política y el periodismo global que nos
que nos que nos enseñe que nos que nos
devoramos esto pero no creo que tenga
grandes implicancias yo lo yo lo que veo
lo que dije al inicio creo que esto es
un ejemplo más que que estamos viendo
que cada transparencia como un valor de
época Y esto es una confirmación más que
es muy difícil Nuevamente si Se confirma
y uno a veces tiene que ser escéptico
sino cínico de que esto fue filtrado a
través de un gamer de grupos extremos
qué sé yo te das cuenta lo fácil que es
ahora filtrar información muy secreta o
muy tóxica
y Andrés su opinión sobre la posición de
Rusia para ir cerrando este tema
bueno en efecto los rusos se ven
bastante felices sobre todo porque les
encanta ver vulnerabilidad en Estados
Unidos no la la su percepción debe de
ser como de una especie de triunfo
mediático visual político etcétera lo
que es interesante lo que dicen los
documentos sobre Rusia es que hablan de
que hay muchísima
tensión al interior del gabinete o entre
los comandantes rusos sobre cómo va la
guerra ve tú a saber si es cierto o no
pero si los rusos saben que los
estadounidenses saben eso Pues sí puede
tener algún efecto Interesante pero pues
la verdad es que como bien dice Iván la
información no se siente especialmente
transformadora de la realidad y y bueno
vayan aseguraba que ni siquiera era
nueva que parece que es información
medio vieja de todo saber si es cierto
también pero pues ese es más o menos la
la percepción que tengo del asunto
pues así vamos cerrando este episodio
Este primer tema para el programa de hoy
primer tema de conversación con nuestros
invitados Les propongo que vayamos
entonces a América Latina hablemos de
temas de nuestra región Porque con el
ánimo de relanzar esas relaciones entre
China y Brasil el presidente brasileño
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva llegó a
Beijing una visita que es tomada como el
regreso de este país suramericano en la
escena internacional Lula va con una
ambiciosa agenda comercial y también
política que busca revivir por ejemplo
el grupo de los brics fortalecerlo
nuevamente en el escenario internacional
también acercar a China al mercosur y
ganar apoyo para ese plan que tiene el
presidente Lula da Silva de aspirar a un
puesto en el Consejo de Seguridad de la
ONU y también presidir el g20 y bueno Y
también ratificar su deseo de ser una
suerte de mediador internacional en la
Guerra de Ucrania así la propuesta de
ceder la Península de crimea a Rusia no
le haya gustado para nada a los
ucranianos y no haya quedado muy parado
Brasil en ese escenario internacional o
por lo menos ante el gobierno en quiebre
comienzo aquí en el estudio con Stefano
ambiciosa la agenda que tiene Lula muy
deseoso por estrechar nexos con con
china cuando otro de sus países aliados
que incluso tiene buenas relaciones
Estados Unidos y China trata de mantener
a Estados Unidos bueno los dos países
tratan de mantener una tensa relación sí
diría que una una ambición compartida
por china también porque es interesante
analizar Esta visita de Lula da Silva
que recordamos fue retrasada por dos
semanas debido a problemas de salud pero
China sinalo desde el principio que
estaban listo para darle la bienvenida
Cuando Tan pronto fuera posible indica
también una gran intención por parte de
China de seguir hablándole a América
Latina de seguir presentándose como un
Aliado como una un compañero
confiable para América Latina y es
interesante hacerle un contraste con lo
que ocurrió cuando en el primer viaje
nacional segundo viaje internacional de
Lula en Estados Unidos Fue en Febrero de
este año donde realmente la agenda se
quedó un poco corta ves Lula viajó
solamente por dos días Ahorita en China
está viajando por cinco días allá viajó
Lula solo en este caso está viajando con
creo que son ocho ministros cinco
gobernadores y un montón de empresarios
brasileños también de empresario La idea
es enlazar hasta 20 tratados bilaterales
entre China y Brasil había mucha
expectativa que la administración biden
en febrero se comprometiera con una
donación importante al fondo de
protección de la amazonía que organizó
Brasil hace años y esto no ocurrió y
vemos Que una vez que que la visita de
Washington se quedó un poco cortada en
las expectativas se organizó esta grande
visita de altísimo perfil
quiero citar una columna que salió esta
hoy justo hoy por parte de Oliver
analista que escribe para
que dice los chinos saben muy bien de
protocolo y la alfombra roja que le
están lanzando a Lula da Silva en esta
esta semana indica que ellos están
realmente serios para presentarse como
el Partner principal a nivel comercial
político geopolítico para América Latina
y es interesante Entonces analizarlo no
solamente a la luz de lo que está
ocurriendo en Europa y en Estados Unidos
sino también a la luz de relaciones Sur
mientras que obviamente la mirada del
Norte en este momento es fija hacia
Ucrania desde Sudamérica latina se ve
mucho más hacia el extremo Oriente tengo
ese tema para para conversarlo y para
preguntárselo así como se está mostrando
Lula como un interlocutor de América
Latina está tomando Lula le dejo la
pregunta ahí de una vez en la mesa para
que la vaya pensando está tomando Lula
ese liderazgo en América Latina que no
han podido tomar ni Boris ni Petro Y
estos movimientos y esta y estos viajes
a nivel internacional le están dando esa
posibilidad de hacerlo le preguntó ahora
entonces Andrés para hacer la ronda la
inversa Vamos hasta México para conocer
impresiones de lo que significa Este
viaje de Lula da Silva y con muchas
ambiciones y en dos puntos clave brix y
mercosur dos responsabilidades muy
grandes que se echa Lula en la espalda
para para relanzarlo bricks en
particular le interesa mucho a China que
vuelva a tener un resurgimiento o un
relanzamiento internacional
absolutamente pero una cosa Antes yo
creo mi percepción de ver la agenda de
Lula creo que el tema de Ucrania en
realidad ha sido más mediático que
realista yo no creo que Lula
sinceramente crea que puede contribuir
de forma significativa resolver ese
problema pero le gustaba la idea
internacional de ponerse como el
el organizador o promotor de la paz y de
un nuevo plan etcétera En efecto como
decías pues lo que ha propuesto no ha
sonado muy muy creíble y creo que
realmente Esa no es su agenda la yo creo
que la agenda es en efecto económica
pero también política quiere relanzar
estos bloques porque han perdido mucho
poder después de los giros
geopolíticos latinoamericanos entre
derecha izquierda que han causado que
los órdenes entre y los acuerdos entre
países se desorden se desorganicen mucho
Pero por otro lado es una estrategia
diplomática porque Lula está
aprovechando muy astutamente el
conflicto entre China y Estados Unidos
para crear su propia persona
internacional distanciarse y eso le
sirve en efecto para presionar a los
Estados Unidos es un poco lo que hace
México con Cuba no cada vez que tenemos
un problema con Estados Unidos nos
acercamos a Cuba y viceversa Son son
métodos de de construcción de equilibrio
y contrapesos internacionales y sobre
todo lo que Lula necesita es dar enormes
resultados económicos o sea tiene que
demostrar que puede sacar a Brasil
adelante después del el mazmo en el que
ha estado y reposicionarlo
internacionalmente después del gobierno
bolsonaro que por supuesto desprestigió
bastante a ese país claro es que son
piezas de una cadena unos eslabones que
no están al azar incluso ese comentario
sobre la Península de crimea Tal vez no
sea una apuesta seria por parte de la
diplomacia brasileña pero solamente
logró que el mundo entero estuviera
hablando de una por lo menos una
propuesta hecha desde América Latina que
es una región a la que le han criticado
mucho tener alguna posición frente a la
guerra en Ucrania y han criticado a los
gobiernos por no tomar ningún ningún
tipo de rumbo frente a esto y aquí por
lo menos Brasil pues propuso algo y no
cayó bien en kiev pero el mundo entero
habló de eso iban su conclusión y su
perspectiva sobre Esta visita que me
imagino que desde Argentina la están
siguiendo con mucho detalle por los
intereses que hay con el mercosur y
porque yo creo que los mandatarios de
Uruguay Paraguay y de Argentina pues les
hubiera encantado tener una visita en
China como la ha tenido el presidente
Lula con toda su disposición
Mira yo juro principalmente chile y
Argentina es lo que más me dedico la
interna creo que yo le voy a dar una un
poco diferente mira creo que esto es un
gran triunfo para para china porque
porque por primera vez O sea china tuvo
hasta hace dos años en general creo lo
han dicho tuvo cancha abierta Tuvo Tuvo
barra abierta en América Latina
a nivel de inversiones a nivel de entrar
el Boom de los commodis los hizo a
muchos países de América Latina que no
tenían acceso a financiamiento los
mercados internacionales no a tener
relaciones especiales con china china Lo
usó como su estrategia y su geopolítica
y ahora hace un año y medio dos más allá
de la Guerra Fría Estados Unidos china
Estados Unidos está realmente interesado
en América Latina No necesariamente
Porque porque nos queda más que antes
sino que por el litio por la energía
renovable Entonces ve a China como un
rival y baileen ha tenido
ha implementado
implementado
dos dos políticas que que hacen que le
pelea al terreno si uno quiere exportar
litio a Estados Unidos no puede hacerlo
con china entonces china qué está
haciendo china le está prestando ropa a
Lula está prestando un escenario para
que no la secuestre como un gran líder y
le está mostrando está mandando un
mensaje a Estados Unidos que está que le
van a dar la pelea porque los países no
los nuestros necesitamos financiamiento
hay algunos países que tienen más acceso
a financiamiento para su desarrollo que
otros y chile está dispuesto a entrar y
está dispuesto a hacerlo bastante
agresivamente hay un dato que no tiene
que ver directamente con con lo que con
la visita de Lula a China pero que tiene
que ver con con las intenciones y las
ambiciones de China América Latina en él
el gigante italiano que se está
desprendiendo de algunos activos en
América Latina y en Europa vendió se
salió de Perú que la compró por un
precio que todos los que saben un
poquito más que yo el mercado energético
casi tres mil millones de dólares y hoy
en día ahora china controla toda la
energía distribución eléctrica de Lima
una de las grandes urbes bueno la
capital de Perú y eso te da como poco a
poco su podría económico lo está
transfiriendo también en poder no
político en Chile indirectamente ya
controla el 57% de la generación y
distribución no de la energía y la
mayoría es energía renovable solar
entonces para cerrar un para dar vuelta
la tu pregunta es su gran triunfo para
Luna absolutamente Luna necesita también
Mostrar la porque tiene la mitad del
país en Brasil que que un poquito menos
a la mitad y No necesariamente lo que él
tiene que Mostrar logros pero creo que
esto para china sí es un momento de
oportunidad para los dos además que por
la región también han pasado otras
figuras internacionales el canciller
Alemán estuvo también por Suramérica
precisamente allá dando ese terreno para
para la los recursos que tiene nuestra
región de cara esa transición energética
y Estados Unidos por ahora por aquí no
ha venido biden a visitar ningún país
por el momento
Stefano respondiendo la pregunta que le
hacía entonces
Lula empieza a tomar ese ese liderazgo
regional volverse de vuelta el hermano
mayor de América Latina Bueno creo que
él tiene obviamente esta ambición por
razones biográficas porque estuvo ese su
tercer mandato es no sé si es una
gráficamente el más mayor de todos los
líderes de la nueva segunda ola rosa si
así queremos llamarla pero seguramente
es el políticamente el más conocido es
el único que tiene realmente un perfil
internacional la remarcado en el
escenario internacional también maneja
el país que
que solamente por su propio peso puede
manejar puede cambiar los equilibrios de
la región o sea una voz que
latinoamérica puede jugar mucho sobre el
cambio climático el medio ambiente los
recursos renovables obviamente la
transición y obviamente
Brasil controla el 60% de la amazonía
controla
largamente el más grande productor de
rubro y materias primas entonces Claro
que que es Brasil el punto que los otros
países de América Latina le miran a
Brasil para hacer que la voz de América
Latina se se escuche en el resto del
mundo y Lula lo sabe y aprovecha de esta
de esta situación seguramente no va a
ser la la única visita de Gran escala a
nivel internacional que vaya a ser el
presidente Lula da Silva en los próximos
meses
ya tiene anunciado creo en estos días
que va a ser huésped en la Cumbre del g7
en España creo que la próxima este
verano
Petro y borich no son invitados
estas posiciones importantes que
mencionaba John un asiento en el Consejo
de Seguridad y liderar el g20 a partir
del año entrante también posiciones de
importantes a nivel internacional
dejamos la visita del presidente de
Brasil a China la dejamos por el momento
una visita que todavía tiene mucha tela
para cortar pero tengo que avanzar con
otro tema que tengo para el programa Y
es chile porque esta semana El Congreso
de ese país aprobó reducir la jornada
laboral de 45 a 40 horas eso no suena
para nada mal pues por lo menos así lo
veo yo Ecuador y chile Son los únicos
países de América Latina en reducir las
horas de trabajo en el caso de chile
esta medida va a ser implementada de
manera escalonada en un plazo de cinco
años y la propuesta también prevé la
posibilidad de trabajar cuatro días y
descansar tres días a ustedes como les
suena comienzo Entonces por Iván para
hacer la ronda la inversa a mí me suena
bastante bien Además que algunos países
europeos que ya han reducido la jornada
laboral y han encontrado que la gente
puede ser mucho más eficiente más
efectiva en sus horas de trabajo que con
las prolongadas horas que tenemos en
América Latina
Sí bueno esto primero es el primer gran
triunfo del gobierno de borich esto es
un proyecto que lanzó la que es ahora su
vocera la la Camila vallejos del partido
comunista lo lanzó primero el 2017
cuando era diputada y la verdad que esto
es un ejemplo dentro de lo crispado que
ha estado chile en los últimos años de
que sí se pueden llegar a grandes
acuerdos esto contó con la aprobación
del 90% del espectro político la extrema
derecha Ultra es la única que le votó en
contra los empresarios lo apoyaron Así
que desde el punto de vista político es
un gran triunfo del puesto desde el
punto de vista humano bueno Nosotros
siempre miramos a Europa occidental a la
social democracia no guerra como un
modelo y esto es acercando a ese modelo
uno de la del del de las cosas que
generaba este malestar que que se hizo
sentir violentamente en 2019 en Chile
con el famoso estallido uno de esos era
el tema del transporte la gente que
vivía en la periferia tenía que tomarse
uno o en el metro que es el del sistema
central subterráneo o buses para llegar
a su trabajo lo mismo A la vuelta y esto
dar flexibilidad y tener 40 horas es un
gran alivio y para los empresarios que
estaban de acuerdo en principio también
era flexibilidad algo que jamás hubiese
pensado con un gobierno de izquierda lo
lo aprobara que es muy cercano a los
sindicatos pero las empresas nosotros
estamos de acuerdo pero tienen que haber
flexibilidad lo que tú mencionaste
podemos darle cuatro días de diez y que
se puedan tomar el fin de semana pueden
dar tomar una sexta etcétera eso de la
flexibilidad también es un gran es un
gran avance Así que yo creo que esto es
un buen político una victoria política
para el gobierno y como sociedad creo
que para Chile es un avance primera
cierto político del presidente Boris
cruzó acá al estudio con Stefano y
Cierro la ronda con Andrés en México
pues primero el periodismo independiente
no tiene horarios así que me gustaría
poder autolimitarme a 40 horas o a
cuatro días
no obviamente es bueno capaces haciendo
una una reflexión más a largo plazo que
América Latina
siga avanzando de una cierta manera
Obviamente con su retraso obviamente
tres pasos adelante y dos atrás pero
esta es un signo que bueno el desarrollo
avanza y y bueno no Victoria como él
dijo de una batalla que se liberó desde
2017 seis años después bueno se ven los
frutos y capaz otros países de América
Latina Colombia quizás puede ser podría
podrían tomarle de tomarle la nota Pero
obviamente bueno es lindo remarcar una
noticia positiva claro un beneficio para
los trabajadores y la lupa está en Chile
en este momento para ver cómo les va con
esta medida que va a ir siendo
implementada de manera escalonada antes
para cerrar la ronda adelante
a mí me parece algo
fundamental es el hecho de que sea
escalonado porque yo estoy seguro que en
la negociación con los empresarios y
para ganar su apoyo es que no fuera
inmediato y chile es un país que le
gusta mucho la gradualidad por eso
también todo su proceso Constituyente de
pronto se sintió demasiado radical y
terminó colapsando pero lo que es
interesante es chile es un país con
contradicciones que me parece
interesante no con el gobierno de
bachelet se logró por ejemplo los
los derechos de maternidad no de que
fueron laboral que pudieras te cubrieran
en el trabajo que no te pudieran
despedir etcétera ella realmente pasó
una ley muy de Avanzada para América
Latina sobre protección a las madres e
incluso a los padres Hasta cierto punto
y otra cosa es que han logrado
establecer por ejemplo con un éxito que
en México no hemos tenido la obligación
de garantizarle condiciones laborales
seguras y y protegidas a las personas
que trabajan en el hogar sin embargo es
una contradicción en el sentido de que
igual tienen un problema brutal con los
con las Afores y con sus tu sistema de
jubilación etcétera entonces es un
avance que me parece crucial Me parece
que lo manejaron muy bien y en efecto
como decían mis colegas es absolutamente
crucial para boric tener Este triunfo
porque cualquiera que vea medios
chilenos sabe que de lo único de lo que
hablan es de delincuencia es el único
que habla o sea es el tema que domina
absolutamente la prensa ahora han matado
unos carabineros Y entonces lo están
acosando con mucha este también o con
mucho objetivo político Por esa razón
pero al final esto empieza a cumplir con
la gran promesa izquierdista con la que
llegó boric de mejorar la vida de las
personas no sin embargo nomás para
terminar comparto lo que dice Stefano o
sea cuándo trabajas sí cuatro días a la
semana si uno trabaja todo todos los
días es terrible sí los periodistas no
no nos detenemos la información No
termina Este programa podría durar horas
con la cantidad de temas que tenemos de
hecho ya se nos está acabando el tiempo
y tengo que agilizar porque tenemos
muchas cosas para abarcar paso ahora a
hacer nuestro comentario del programa
les doy un otro tema de la actualidad
que ha tenido lugar a lo largo de la
semana de hacer un comentario rápido
sobre sobre lo que deja esta esta
noticia y la percepción o el punto de
vista que tienen sobre ello y eso nos
tiene que llevar otra vez a la Esfera
internacional nos saca América Latina y
nos lleva hasta ese vigésimo quinto
aniversario de la firma del acuerdo de
viernes Santo una fecha aprovechada por
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden para visitar las dos irlandes yo
les pido entonces a ustedes que hagan un
comentario sobre este tema comienzo
entonces comienzo con Andrés para hacer
la ronda a la inversa y Andrés adelante
su comentario sobre este aniversario
bueno es una fecha que es absolutamente
crucial en la historia de
el Reino Unido y de y de Europa en
general porque haber logrado la paz
Después de tanto tiempo de los problemas
como le decían y de tanta violencia y
tanto miedo sin duda tiene un efecto
crucial en
recordarnos que la paz es posible y hoy
en día con el tema de Ucrania y etcétera
es muy bueno que la sociedad recuerde
que la paz es posible creo que ha sido
una buena oportunidad para volver a
recordar cómo se solucionan los
conflictos el conflicto originalmente
parecía insoluble no iba a terminar
jamás y sin embargo lo lograron resolver
no la salida de la Unión Europea causó
bastantes tensiones y recuerdo que
cuando el brexit había mucha ansiedad en
Irlanda sobre que volvieran a empezar
estos problemas al cerrar la frontera no
sin embargo pues parece que no sucedió y
su celebración ahora pues es es un
bonito recordatorio de que también
podemos resolver las cosas bien no ha
sido un triunfo para biden también
términos internacionales porque lo han
tratado como una estrella de rock pero
claro Creo que creo que es un buen
momento para recordar cómo se resuelven
las cosas significativo porque Estados
Unidos fue importante para esa
negociación Y porque también es el país
de donde viene su familia generaciones
atrás yo me uno a eso que dice Andrés de
esa posibilidad de lograr la paz y
alcanzarla pero también esa negociación
que hubo que hacer para el marco del
brexit eso también nos nos dejan
evidencia lo difícil que también Es
mantenerla que creo que es una de las de
los otros puntos que también deja este
acuerdo 25 años después Iván no nos
olvidamos de usted Por supuesto que no
su opinión su comentario
Mira Yo viví 13 años en Inglaterra soy
un tengo una parte de mi corazón
británico
y la verdad que yo soy un gran
proponente que los países la sociedad y
los países que avanzan en la historia
empírica
muestra que los acuerdos los países que
llegan a acuerdos avanzan más que los
que no y llevamos ya varios años en
nuestra región en en Gran Bretaña con el
tema brexit en Estados Unidos con el
trampismo en nuestra región en Brasil
Chile argentino o lo que lo que acá
llamado Una grieta y la verdad que no la
como digo esto esto este acuerdo estos
25 años si está todo esta ceremonia con
la pompa que que rodea la visita de
biden por ahí nos hacen acordarnos a
todos de que los avances se hacen cuando
ambas partes se ven y se aíslan los
extremos Así que desde ese punto de
vista lo veo como un ejemplo que a lo
mejor no diga Bueno pongamos un poco la
pelota al piso usando una analogía
futbolista y y veamos que forma los
cuarenta años más los cuarenta horas en
Chile veo lo mismo y acá desde el punto
de vista política creo es un triunfo
también para biden porque porque la
verdad que en Estados Unidos El Love
Irlandés tiene una influencia política
bastante grande bastante grande para
cerrar la ronda de comentarios Stefano
Bueno muy rápidamente las cosas buenas
uno se da cuenta que existen solamente
cuando se las quitan y creo que en este
momento la reflexión sobre el acuerdo
del viernes Santo es que buena
institución que fue la Unión Europea que
bueno fue haber logrado que
20 y pasa de países pudiesen ponerse de
acuerdo levantar la frontera porque es
en este momento cuando ese acuerdo fue
puesto en discusión por el brexit que
uno se da cuenta de lo valioso que fue
esta institución que obviamente tiene
sus problemas yo soy europeo nadie me lo
tiene que repetir de cuánto mal funciona
la Unión Europea pero aún funcionando
mal es una institución muy positiva y
en este caso permitió hacer la paz y
bueno verlo bueno reflexionar sobre eso
y grandes logros que ha tenido la Unión
Europea en sus fronteras no solamente en
la escena internacional llegamos al
bloque final del programa me quedan un
par de minutos y me gusta cerrar
preguntándole a nuestros invitados
Cuáles son los temas que van a tener en
la lupa para la siguiente semana en sus
redacciones en sus reportajes o temas
que están trabajando a lo largo de estos
días por ejemplo también puede ser otra
otra forma de responder comienzo
entonces dándole la palabra a Iván Qué
temas hay bajo la lupa entonces próximos
días allí en Argentina
en Argentina un tema muy candente es la
visita actual del ministro de economía
Sergio massa que está en las reuniones
del Banco Mundial y el fondo monetario
que llegan a su a su máxima expresión
este fin de semana Argentina necesita
plata como siempre está tratando de
conseguir nuevos financiamiento y el
fondo monetario con el apoyo de Estados
Unidos
le dé más flexibilidad hay una sequía
que va a generar muchos problemas para
tener Y es un daño electoral en una
política que está muy complicada y en
Chile te digo que se viene estamos en la
recta final a las elecciones para la
nueva asamblea Constituyente en el marco
justo el creo que es el viernes el
jueves veinte rápido es el evento
empresarial más importante va a ir el
presidente se espera que le tire un
salvavidas una forma de llegar porque se
beneficia esas elecciones muy
importantes Stefano sus temas presidente
Petro se va para Estados Unidos el lunes
en Nueva York que el martes en San
Francisco miércoles y jueves se queda en
Washington supuestamente no tiene agenda
obviamente está allí tocándole el
campanillo a bailan vamos a ver si se
logra esta bilateral
y en México Andrés sus temas para el
cierre bueno el tema que nos tiene
consumidos en este momento fue la
tragedia de Ciudad Juárez donde cuarenta
migrantes murieron quemados en una
estación migratoria han estado
repatriando a los cuerpos y
esta semana la fiscalía general de la
república anunció que iba a iniciar una
investigación contra el el comisionado
de la de la del Instituto Nacional de
Migración Francisco garduño para ver si
tenía responsabilidad penal Francisco
garduño es muy cercano al presidente su
amigo lo ha protegido y ha dicho que no
lo va a quitar a menos de que lo
impongan cargos criminales
verdaderamente garduño se ha mantenido
en absoluta oscuridad Yo creo que ni ha
salido de su casa no ha hablado ni una
sola vez con la prensa sobre este caso
Andrés Iván Stefano Muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en
una semana en el mundo recorrido por los
hechos más destacados de la semana
conversados aquí entre periodistas desde
nuestro punto de vista
Les agradecemos a ustedes por haber
estado con nosotros hoy la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y Andrés
doncel y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera y
Natalie Quiroga siga con France 24 y
sigan dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
[Música]